the cast of Brooklyn nine-nine is on
season seven and they are still in
disbelief
congratulations season seven what are
you feeling
unicorn like yes very unicorn leg I'm
pleased I never thought we'd be here
seven seasons later I was actually in
Europe a little while ago and people
were like Brooklyn nine-nine is my
favorite show and I'm in Spain and that
is the power of the people y'all
remember the show was canceled by Fox
then the very next day
NBC snatched it up and it's already been
renewed for season eight that's good
news for Melissa who was pregnant in our
interview she had a baby boy Axl on
Valentine's Day made us wonder would
they write a baby into the show it was
teed up a little last year so that's a
fair question how do you think would
change the series though is there like a
whole spin-off behind the scenes this
cast loves to pull pranks but if someone
needed real help who'd get the call
Andre I call Terry we can you call it
like 3:00 a.m. it's gonna pick up cuz
Andy's gonna pick up no everyone said
don't call Andy he won't pick up the
phone at 3:00 a.m. that's right they
were correct oh yeah okay I don't my
phone's not on in the middle of the
night if there's an emergency I people
know how to reach me
it's not like I know CPR or something
[Music]